within the department based on the
appearance of loyalty
to the president rather than the caliber
of their qualifications
compounding this problem multiple senior
level saline officers in the department
have gone unfilled
necessitating the installment of career
or mid-level officials into senior
positions
in an acting capacity finally the
president
undermined our military justice system
and chain of command by pardoning troops
credibly accused including by their
peers of war crimes
moreover we are facing extraordinary
challenges the world is engulfed in a
global pandemic that is sick and
millions of americans
cause hundreds of thousands of deaths
and produce severe
economic damage we are the victim of the
largest cyber breach on record
perpetrated by the russians
last wednesday the capital was stolen by
a mob whose intent was to prevent
congress
from performing its constitutional duty
to certify the election
this attack was the greatest threat to
constitutional order
in my lifetime and it shocked our allies
while giving comfort and confidence to
our adversaries around the globe
when the committee considers general
austin's nomination next week we will
thoroughly review this nomination
in the historic context is being
presented and the impact it will have on
future generations
therefore as we discussed the importance
of civilian control the armed forces
this morning
i hope our witnesses can speak to the
following issues
first i'd like your views on how to
encourage diversity of opinion
within department of defense when
crafting policy
and making national security decisions
rather than tilting
one way to the military or completely
the other way to the civilian
second i would like our witnesses
thoughts on whether providing a way will
encourage senior military officers to be
more political
and if they believe it could lead to a
situation where future presidents will
default
to nominating retired general officers
for the position of secretary defense in
lieu of qualified civilians
third if congress provides a waiver for
general austin i would like our
witnesses to share their thoughts on the
impact this will have on the durability
of the existing statute
finally if general austin is ultimately
confirmed as a secretary of defense
i would welcome any recommendations from
our witnesses on actions he could take
to ensure his tenure protects and
promotes the principle
of civilian control of the military
civilian control of military
consistent with the constitution begins
and ends with the commander-in-chief
it is the bedrock of our democracy and
it is the principle that president-elect
biden values and respects
serving on this committee and providing
oversight and department of defense is a
great privilege and an enormous
responsibility
one that i take seriously the events of
the past several months have thrown the
sharp relief how
perishly close our nation has come to
undermining the resiliency of our
democratic institutions
while not broken these institutions and
principles have been repeatedly subject
to extreme stress
this dire situation calls for stability
and a duly confirmed sector defense
who has responded to congress in the
confirmation process
and will be responsive to congress as
well as the president
in the execution of his duties as we
hear from our witnesses today
consider an exceptional general austin
to serve the secretary of defense
i expect that the best will the debate
rather will be robust and spirited
but i'm also confident that we'll be
respectful as every member of this
committee cares deeply about our men and
women's uniform
their family and the civilians and
contractors who serve in the department
of defense
and thank you very much mr chairman
and uh with the chairman's uh
direction and permission uh let me
recognize
uh our witnesses for their testimony
and if dr cohen you may begin
good morning mr chairman um i ask that
my written testimony be made apart
without objection mr chairman mr ranking
member
senators i am grateful for the
opportunity to be here today
i would like to note that i am speaking
in my personal capacity and my views do
not
represent those of the us naval war
college or of any other organ of the us
government
there are important principles and
values at stake here
some of which way for granting mr austin
a waiver and some of which weigh against
it
i will do my best to lay out what i see
as the most important
issues at stake so that you can make the
most informed decision possible
on the pro side are the principles that
the president
should generally be allowed to choose
his or her own people
unless there is a good reason to deny
them and that it is critical to break
down the significant barriers faced by
people of color and other
underrepresented groups in the national
security
world and the world of governance more
broadly
on these two points mr austin has a
strong case
on the con side are several concerns
about principles of civilian control of
the military
civil military relations more generally
and ultimately democratic governance
this is where i will focus my remarks
but i
emphasize that systemic racism is as
much a danger to principles of
democratic governance as breakdowns in
civilian control
the first point to address is why this
law exists at all as the chairman asked
what the principle of civilian control
is and why it's important
the law stems from a moment in which the
u.s was creating a permanent national
defense establishment of unprecedented
size
scope and responsibility and congress
was motivated to ensure
that this establishment would be firmly
under political
rather than uniformed military control
since then
the size and power of the department of
defense has arguably
grown it remains important therefore
that this enormous commitment of public
resources and american lives
be subject and accountable to political
authority
and not solely to its own internal
judgment
the principle of civilian control is
about ensuring that the military
organization
serves the purposes of the republic
rather than serving its own
organizational judgment or purposes
there are multiple mechanisms for
achieving this and the more mechanisms
there are in place
the more secure the principle is some of
these mechanisms are appropriate for a
democratic republic to use
others are not legitimate mechanisms
include having institutional structures
that place politically appointed or
elected civilians in positions of
authority
over the highest uniformed military
officers a legal system
that holds military personnel
accountable to laws made by congress
and a professional military ethic of
subordination to political control
not legitimate for a democratic republic
are mechanisms like
pervasive ideological surveillance and
forcing loyalty to a ruling ideology
making the officer corps consist largely
of whatever demographic group
holds political power so
typically in the public or national
interest
a military logic for those within the
military it is natural to want to
approach a fight with overwhelming
resources
overwhelming force and few limitations
on how they can employ that force
by the political logic of why force is
being used in the first place
in some the principle of civilian or
political control of the military is
central both to healthy democratic
governance
and to effective use of forced political
ends
one of the several important mechanisms
for exercising that control is civilian
political appointees exercising
political
rather than military logic in positions
of authority
so those are the concerns relating to
civilian control there are also concerns
relating to issues of civil military
relations and governance
the first is that granting this waiver
would weaken the principle that
civilians should be in control of the
defense department
and would very likely lead to more
appointments of recently retired
officers
should that happen there is the
potential for further politicization of
the officer corps
by which i mean an undesirable increase
in either the reality or perception of
military officers
engaging in the usually partisan
struggle for political power
within the the domestic system something
we've already noted as unhealthy
third is that this appointment is likely
to strengthen a general perception
that military experience and expertise
are the same thing as security defense
or foreign policy expertise
they are not the same and it is
important that both be well represented
in defence
and security policy making in short as
hamilton warned
if the people believe that only
professional military officers
understand how to protect them
it is a short step to the belief that
only professional military officers
know how to govern them fourth is the
issue of public trust in the system and
in political institutions
choosing a recently retired general
officer and arguing that he is uniquely
qualified to meet the current challenges
furthers a narrative that military
officers are better at things
and more reliable or trustworthy than
civil servants or other civilians
this is hugely problematic at a time
when one of the biggest challenges
facing the country
is the need to restore trust and faith
in the political system
implying that only a military officer
can do this job
at this time is counterproductive to
that goal
there is also a danger that elected
officials may use the public's trust in
the military
to avoid difficult parts of politics
military personnel should not be used as
shields for political choices
in order to restore trust and confidence
in the system elected officials must
embrace the responsibility
of making the public case for difficult
choices
well i've argued that this nomination is
troubling on grounds of healthy
governance and institutions
there are several ways that these
concerns could be mitigated
uh things that both these chambers and
mr austin and the biden administration
can do
i've outlined these in my written
statement and i'm happy to elaborate
there are ways in which granting this
waiver and confirming mr austin will
make
efforts to restore trust in the
political system more difficult
should this chamber choose that path it
will be important to ensure that the
administration is doing what it can
to rebuild civilian expertise and
authority in the department of defense
and the government more broadly
in other ways mr austin may be the right
person for the job at this moment
the president-elect will need his team
to work together smoothly and seamlessly
to deal with the extreme challenges they
face both domestically and abroad
mr austin's leadership could be a step
in the right direction of diversifying
the upper levels of the national
security establishment
our country faces a difficult time and
the incoming administration must balance
a number of competing priorities
central among them the need to restore
the legitimacy of the principles and
institutions of democratic governance mr
austin's nomination will neither heal
nor break american democracy by itself
but it is a critical node in the web
thank you and i look forward to your
questions
well thank you very much and let you now
recognize
uh our other witness dr mcginnis thank
you doctor and
i just remind you if you can stay close
to the five minutes we'd appreciate it
thank you
good morning mr chairman i ask that my
written testimony may be made part of
the record
without objection thank you thank you mr
chairman and mr ranking member for the
opportunity to join you this morning to
discuss civilian control of the armed
forces
it is an honor to be here for this
conversation on behalf of the
congressional research service
the founding fathers placed limits on
the armed forces in order to ensure that
the military is both subordinate and
accountable to the political leadership
of the united states
control of the armed forces is a shared
responsibility
of both the executive and legislative
branches
tensions arise of course but the
fundamental subordination of the
military to the civilians that they
serve
has remained intact due to careful
oversight in daily management by both
branches of the u.s government
100 years 150 years after the founding
the experience of world war ii convinced
many including president truman
of the need for greater coordination of
a larger standing military in a single
defense department
yet concerns were raised that a single
individual serving as head of all the us
armed forces might become too powerful
and even more so if that person had
previously served as a military officer
this concern led to the provision
commonly referred to as the cooling off
period between military service and
second f appointment
at the time the period was 10 years in
2008
congress reduced it to seven years there
have been two exceptions to that waiting
period for general marshall in 1950 and
for general mattis in 2017.
four years ago this committee heard
testimony on the risks that confirming a
recently retired general
officer into the position of secretary
of defense might introduce
it was observed that tactical and
operational leadership
especially within a deeply hierarchical
and non-partisan institution like the
military
does not necessarily provide adequate
preparation for the complexity of a
secretary of defense's inherently
political roles
the sec the position of secretary of
defense is unique within the us
government
they serve as the principal adviser to
the president on defense matters
they are the only unelected civilian
leader in the military chain of command
they are responsible for adjudicating
budget disputes
they represent dod in interagency
discussions
they serve as a key node for congress's
oversight and civilian control of the
military they manage one of the largest
workforces in the world
they serve as a point of communication
between the department of defense and
the american public
and all the while they must constantly
and vigorously protect the military from
politicization
those tasks are a tall order for anybody
so success depends upon the health of
the department of defense as an
institution and in particular
the office of the secretary of defense
the the latter helps
the secretary provide routine civilian
oversight over the department
a growing course of defense experts
argue that those civilian institutions
are now
at a low point some reasons for this
assessment
include failures to nominate and confirm
experienced and effective political
appointees which has allowed
if not encouraged other institutions in
dod to marginalize civilian leadership
on matters such as planning
and mandated headquarters personnel
reductions which have served to increase
the workload
on a shrinking staff in the face of an
increasingly dangerous strategic
landscape
according to this view in order for the
secretary to provide effective authority
direction and control over the armed
forces
these institutions ought to be
revitalized
now these issues existed when secretary
mattis assumed the reins of the
department of defense
and for a variety of reasons they have
since accelerated
observers argue that the net result has
been to create an inversion of the
civilian military relations dialogue
with the military now more dominant on
defense matters
on a day-to-day basis than their
civilian counterparts
this is why the bipartisan national
defense strategy commission stated that
they were struck by the imbalance of
civilian
civilian and military voices on critical
issues of strategy development and
implementation
article 1 section 8 of the constitution
grants congress the power to raise and
supervise the military and by extension
the pentagon
many observers therefore contend that a
top priority for the secretary of
defense in partnership with congress
should be to revitalize and improve dod
civilian institutions and workforce
put a bit differently considerable time
and attention is paid to the health of
the military's personnel equipment and
so on
yet there's no comparable metrics for
civilian workforce health and readiness
regardless of who ultimately sits in the
position of secretary of defense
addressing this matter is an option
congress might want to consider in order
to revitalize civilian control of the
military
and ensure our civilian institutions are
robust enough to do their work
effectively
in conclusion mr chairman the american
government wields its power through the
consent of the govern
the founders intended that this
principle would apply unambiguously to
the military as well
thank you and i await your questions
thank you very much and
now on behalf of chairman inhofe let me
recognize
chairman for his questions
well thank you senator reed i i think
it'd be a good idea
and since can i i mentioned that
i didn't believe that the
a waiting period was really necessary
and then so it wouldn't be necessary to
waive it although i've studied a little
bit more
in the opening statements of both of our
witnesses and so uh
let me just do this i'm going to go
ahead and read
that part of the of the title 10
that is
verbatim here quote i'm quoting now
there is a secretary of defense
who is the head of the department of
defense appointed from civilian life by
the president
by and with the advice and consent of
the senate a person may not be appointed
as secretary of
defense within seven years after relief
uh from active release from active
duty as a commissioned officer of a
regular component of the armed forces
now dr khan you know this is kind of
arbitrary i guess that seven years is a
reason for seven years instead of four
years or one year
or uh in general is this a
threshold that we ought to keep or
should a change
maybe be considered
thank you mr chairman um you are correct
the number seven
is somewhat arbitrary the original
number 10 was also arbitrary
it was a nice round number um and seven
was
uh the compromise between leaving it at
10 and reducing it to five which was the
debate that came up in 2007
2008. however i do think that
seven years is actually a good period
because as multiple
people have pointed out it allows a
minimum of two rotations
for military deployments and and
assignments
which means that that allows time for
the
command relationships and the people in
those command positions to change
significantly from the time that the
recently retired officer was
in a position of command that helps in a
lot of ways to mitigate the problem
that um both you and mr ranking member
mentioned
about mr mattis relying heavily on his
network of military contact
well we're suffering from some
interruptions right now
and i can't tell uh senator reid can you
tell from where you are
what's the cause of those i know sir but
your some members need to put their
their microphones on you dick you need
to be on mute dick blumenthal you're not
on you
so we're getting back from you and
anyone else who's not on mute needs to
mute their
screens that's the back of the black
sound
all right that sounds good to me all
right uh we
we we read that but i also in my opening
statement i talked about the nds the
commission that was
uh and we're following that uh pretty
closely
i i'm going to go ahead and read what
that commission says now this is the nds
i don't have that with me right now but
i do have the
the quote from it it says the report
states civilian voices
have been relatively muted on issues
at the center of the u.s defense and
national security policy
undermining the concept of civilian
control
the implementation of the nds must
feature
empowered civilians fulfilling their
statutory responsibilities
particularly regarding the issues
of force management so starting with
dr khan and then dr mcginnis
you agree with the assessment by the nds
commission that quote civilian voices
are relatively muted and if so
why is this such a big problem in our
democracy
dr khan thank you mr chairman
um i would say yes i do agree with that
assessment i think
that um the civilian side of the
department of defense
has lost both influence
and um respect over the last several
years
and i think that is a problem for the
reasons uh outlined in my written
testimony in terms of the need
for diverse experiences
and particularly the need for an
understanding of what i have called
political logic
that is people who are dedicated to
thinking about defense and security in
policy terms and not just in what we
might think of as practical military
terms
i think that the the military side
is well represented in the debates
internal to the department
what's happening now that is the
civilian side is less well-represented
and that creates an imbalance and i
think produces worse policy
thank you sir well and dr mcginnis you
do you agree i think the key part there
is civilian
voices are relatively muted do you think
so
uh senator uh there is considerable
evidence that's part of the public
record now that suggests that that is
indeed the case that that comports with
the national defense strategy
commission's assessment
um it's worth noting that the office of
the secretary of defense
the civilian voices that are in this
case being
relatively muted is the practical eyes
arms ears legs of the secretary of
defense they are
there to do the day-to-day work of
civilian oversight of the military
they write this they they work with
their counterparts overseas to
understand political military dynamics
that might impact
the national security of the united
states they go to war zones and help
military commanders really understand
the secretary's intent
uh they they they are the the practical
you know where the rubber
meets the road of civilian military
relations the office of the secretary of
defense is where it happens
and according to the national defense
strategy commission as well as
again a growing course of voices that i
referred to in my opening statement
those civilian voices are relatively
muted now
a couple of reasons that that are worth
uh calling attention to
include again this this question of
appointment
of of uh political appointees within the
system
the the failure to do so and having um
civil servants being in acting
capacities has served to if there's
nobody in
the civilian side of the house to do the
work then they're then
the the advice the decisions on
on matters of national strategy are
going to migrate by
inherently to the institutions that are
appropriately staffed why does this
matter
i refer once again to the national
defense strategy and the national
defense strategy commission's
reports the um the ndsc commission notes
that china is engaged in a whole of
society strategy
to accomplish its objectives many of
which are counter to u.s objectives
the political military nature of the
security environment which we are
operating in requires political military
connections and connective tissue
between the military um
instrument and the broader political
objectives of this country
and the pro and the broader uh
prerogatives of the president himself
without the civilian side of the house
without that civilian pillar being able
to do its job effectively
we are missing a critical voice a
critical um
note of the critical connective tissue
in this discussion
if you agree with the uh national
defense strategy commission's report on
this
on this matter well
you know they're we're going to be
having the hearing coming up so
if a waiver is granted i'd like to ask
each one of you what types of questions
should we ask to mitigate some of the
the potential problems that might come
with having the uh the the this
the waiver uh this
here from both of you dr khan and dr
mcginnis
what what should we be pursuing in the
hearing
in the event that this waiver is granted
thank you mr chairman um i think a
couple of questions that you
uh ought to ask mr austin would include
things like
how he plans to demonstrate his
commitment to
um empowering the civilian side of
the department of defense how he plans
to foster
uh relationships of respect and trust
between
the civilian staff and the uniformed
staff
i think you should ask him how he
sees the differences between his role
as a military commanding officer and his
role as the secretary of defense
and and you should want to know that he
is committed to the idea of being a
political actor and no longer
a military actor receiving and obeying
orders or simply giving military advice
that he should be willing to engage with
the press
willing to be transparent with congress
with this committee and with the house
armed services committee
um and that that he should
generally express an understanding
of the uh different nature of the role
that he will be playing
thank you okay uh thank you dr mcginnis
uh
what do you think uh thank you mr
chairman uh the
the question invites us to consider that
the
the secretary of defense is is one
person
um that's put in an institutional role
that is
inherently political inherently
multifaceted
um it's as as one scholar put it it's
the the impossible job within the
department because there's so much to it
and therefore the the health of the
institution of the department of defense
is critically important
to ensuring that the day-to-day business
any any strengths weaknesses whatever
arcs
are are managed and and that the the
business of national security
can can be advanced um
so in order to be effective they need
the the secretary of defense needs to be
have the confidence the president the
congress and the military and the
department of defense
so to that end if if you are interested
in teasing out whether
those relationships will be solid um and
and and
uh comport with what you would
like to see um some suggestions might
include you know
whether or not the the nominee would be
amenable to to to taking a close look at
the civilian the health of the civilian
workforce
also with respect to uh relations with
the congress uh
the you know one one uh
proposal that was tabled last time when
we were considered when
the the nomination of secretary mattis
was considered
was whether or not the then
nominee mattis would testify in front of
the house armed services committee
that might be another option to consider
[Music]
okay that makes sense simply read but
thank you very much mr chairman let me
thank the witnesses again
and i think the chairman has really
focused in on some of the critical
questions that we have to address
but one point is that my reflection on
the context national defense strategy
commission is that
the authors detected this decline in
civilian authority
over several years it wasn't an abrupt
change as a result of general mattis or
anyone else
so this is a tendency that was uh
happening even when we had
you know civilians as secretary of
defense is that's accurate in your view
thank you go ahead kim yes that is
accurate
so we have uh regardless of who the
nominee is a challenge
to restore a much stronger balance
of civilian control and
one factor particularly if
general austin is indeed confirmed would
be to put
robust civilians as quickly as possible
into critical roles like the
undersecretary deputy secretary
the policy secretary is that a strong
view that you would share dr cohn
yes senator i think so very much dr
mcginnis
the the analysis would suggest that sir
yes
and you know i do think that uh the
chairman's questions about the
the issues we should raise your
responses were quite
good in fact very good which is
basically
the understanding that uh general austin
would have
of a new role which is not uh similar to
and i
i believe he is you know he's
intelligent enough to grasp this but he
has to demonstrate
uh not only an intellectual but also a
uh sort of complete commitment to this
which is to
understand that he is in
a political role bureaucratic politics
not electoral politics but bureaucratic
politics
and that he has to rely frankly if he's
given this
opportunity on the expertise
of others that have
much more of that experience and i think
that's
kind of that is consistent with your
comments too
um the other aspect of this is that
yeah even though he is clearly a
professional
in fact a superb professional military
officer
many of his tasks certainly as the
centcom commander
put him face to face with the politic
with very difficult political judgments
so in that context
would you think he would have some
insights already into the political
dynamics of national security policy
dr khan thank you senator
yes of course uh anyone who reaches the
level of four stars
has um political experience of the type
uh involving diplomatic efforts
um thinking about policy significance
they have of course been asked to
provide
advice to policy makers so he certainly
has some of this experience and no one
is questioning either his competency
or his savvy in terms of
understanding political implications i
think the main differences
that that i would point out uh first of
all
his let's say default logic when he
comes to
dealing with problems and issues and
whether the first thing that he thinks
of
is how to achieve larger political goals
using
a wide array of tools and and mechanisms
or whether he thinks of it from the from
the perspective of an army officer
um and the other thing again is that
there are multiple meanings of political
um what you have described is political
in the sense
that it is dealing with bargaining and
that is important
but there is also political in the sense
of the power dynamic especially the
partisan power dynamic
within domestic politics and the
domestic system
and this is something that mr austin
will be aware of but will never have had
to personally
play in and that i think is something
and and we saw with mr mattis that that
was something he was very uncomfortable
doing
um and that is problematic uh given
as dr mcinnis has described the role of
the secretary of defense
thank you dr mcginnis brief comments i
only have about 20 seconds
for sure um the the the question invites
us to consider um
the the the role of of
a combat commander a force document
general officer and the experiences that
they've had
um the the a four-star combatant
commander
has had lots of experience with the
pointing end of the spear and there's a
lot of
political military dynamics associated
with that as you as you point out
um but spears have a huge shaft as well
there's a whole lot of there's a whole
lot that goes into making that
the pointy end of the spear effective
and as a result
you know with it as applied to the
department of defense there's there's
title 10 responsibilities there's
strategy i mean all kinds of different
things that that that
the uh secretary is responsible for so
in consideration of
of this question of civilian military
relations
it invites us to consider the broader
team
and how the the broader team is going to
be able to
handle these responsibilities on behalf
of the nation national security is a
team sport
thank you very much and uh i would ask
my colleagues to try to adhere as close
as possible the five-minute rule and
with that
uh on behalf of chairman inhofe i'd like
to recognize senator fisher
thank you senator um i'd like to explore
a little bit
uh further the quote that senator inhofe
used uh
in the 2018 report from the national
defense strategy commission where
where concern was expressed about the
state of
civil military relations at the time
dr mcginnis and dr cohn what is your
assessment
of a current state of civilian military
relations and do you agree
that this is a trend which is moving in
the wrong direction
uh thank you senator the evidence out
there does
uh comport with the national defense
strategy commission's assessment of
civilian military relations um and
it is you know up to this committee to
determine whether you agree with this
this assessment um but it it it does
suggest that if the civilian pillar
within the department of defense is is
not up to
optimum health and as you rightly point
out these are long-standing trends
um furloughs headquarters reductions
um political points these these are are
issues that that go back at least a
decade
uh we and and have accumulated over time
so if we do want to see healthy civilian
military relations being
conducted on a day-to-day basis it would
argue for
uh paying paying attention to the health
of the civilian workforce and
the political appointees the team that
that is put in to support
uh whoever the the secretary of defense
uh will be
what do you think is the most concerning
uh aspect of it
the example the commission uses is the
empowerment of the joint
staff at the expense of civilian staff
within the office
of secretary um are there other examples
and dr cohn please please jump in as
well
uh there are there are a variety of
manifestations of this issue
one being again the the the failure to
have
uh confirmed political appointees within
positions
uh which you know
combat commanders a joint staff when
they when they look to
look for civilian guidance
and they are confronted with an acting
um who does not have the authority for
the department to make decisions
um in the way that somebody who's been
confirmed does
um they naturally sort of it's it's
human nature they just sort of go around
that but then there's also procedural
elements of this as well
um i dr mara carlin notes
that there are a number of provisions in
statute
uh with respect to the chairman of the
joint chiefs of staff's role uh
statutory responsibilities that sort of
overlap with civilian dimensions of
of policy making in the department um
and and in procedure there's just
how policy how how an instruction is
staffed out and how the war plans are
staffed out and how
how the review process works with
process matters in the pentagon as you
know
uh but looking at some of these
instructions the
the the routine of you know halfway
marks uh
waypoints checkpoints within the process
um
seem to have not included civilian
voices in those
those those um in the procedures
um okay dr cohen if you'd like to speak
to that
and also do you think that when we
create exemptions and allow
um recently retired officers
thank you senator to answer your second
question first
yes i think it does uh of course weaken
the norm or the principle and i think
that that should be an issue of concern
for you as you make this decision but of
course
whether it undermines the norm
completely is up to you
in the future you will have the
opportunity to make this decision again
and you can change uh the direction of
that norm in terms of the civil military
relationships both within the department
of defense and more
broadly in society i think what we have
seen
is a really troubling set of mutually
reinforcing trends
uh negative trends um as dr mcinnis has
described
in the department you have many many
years worth of
hiring freezes personnel cuts um
difficulty uh filling positions with
senate confirmed
members and using acting people or
leaving them vacant
and that is extremely troubling but this
is reinforced
by a larger situation in the american
public of a
worrying trend of over deference to
military expertise and military
experience
and a worrying trend of less
interest in in active self-governance
and a sort of
willingness to turn over decision-making
to the military and i think
these trends are both troubling they are
mutually reinforcing
um and they should be something that
this chamber seriously considers as
something that needs to be addressed
going forward
thank you thank you senator reid uh
thank you senator fisher and again on
behalf of chairman
of let me recognize senator shaheen
well thank you i appreciate the
opportunity to participate in this
hearing
and um one of the things that has come
up several times and your responses dr
conan and dr mcginnis has been
the operating within a partisan
environment which we know
is very much the case right now in
washington that the country
is very divided and this is not exactly
on point
for the waiver but i think it is another
troubling trend within the military
and you mentioned this dr mcginnis in
your june 2020
crs report on the military
that you highlight the importance of
civilian control
but you also reference that
the nonpartisan culture of the military
is one of the reasons
that it has enjoyed such a high regard
in the american public
and i think one of the more recent polls
had 73 percent of
americans who viewed the military with
high regard
but one of the things that is troubling
is that we're seeing more and more
partisanship within the military and
so i wonder as you're as you're thinking
about
the waiver issue and about
what we need to ensure the division
between civilian and military control
if you can speak to whether this is an
issue that is
going to be affected by
granting another waiver and having
further military control
of the department of defense
and how would we how should we handle
that erosion of the nonpartisanship
within the military are there things
that
congress and the executive branch should
be doing to address that
we saw it again and the insurrection at
the capitol
on the sixth that there were a number of
former
military and and actually at least one
active military
participant in that who has since
resigned so
as we think about the the challenges
how should we be thinking about that
aspect of what's going on within the
military
dr mcginnis maybe you could begin
if it's okay i'd like to turn to dr cohn
who is uh has written extensively on
this matter
sure thank you very much senator for
these questions
um i would say uh there are i think your
analysis is is
correct um i would say there are a
couple of things that can be done
to uh deal with this problem in some
ways and the two most important ones
that i can think of
are that um elected officials in general
both in the
executive and in the legislative
branches should
work to protect the military from
partisan politics
do not use them as props do not use them
as shields
do not base your arguments for
legislation
on the effect that they will have on
members of the military and their
families and veterans
these are all of course very important
things members of the military and their
families and veterans have needs
but they are not the only reason to pass
legislation and it's important not to
give that impression to the american
people
that that's the only justification for
many things that need to be done
for other reasons so protect the
military from partisan politics
in terms of what it has to do with this
particular nomination
i would say that the biggest mitigating
factor
would be to uh encourage mr austin to
emphasize his new role and his
separation from
his military role and the fact that what
he is doing is a different
kind of thing than what military
officers do
um and i think that those two things
should help
in the end however partisan polarization
is a broad social phenomenon and our
military is of course representative of
our public or at least we
hope to keep it that way um and the
any phenomena that show up in the
broader society will affect the military
um so in the end we have to work on
partisan polarization as a larger
problem in order to heal it within the
military
thank you thank you dr mcginnis do you
have anything you want to add to that
oh yes i i was struck as dr
khan was speaking about the some of the
other broader trends that are that are
factor in play
in this discussion which is you know
over the years the
the us military has seen the lion's
share of resources uh
allocated towards it and it lion's share
of attention allocated
towards it when it comes to matters of
national security relative to
institutions like the state department
and usaid
so there's this there is a shift towards
focusing on the department of defense
tasks missions are are going over
to the department of defense as a result
and that sort of
raises questions about how we think
about what the
military does for national security
what's its appropriate role and have we
gotten that right
well thank you i appreciate that i think
i'm out of time but
it speaks to the need to rebalance the
role of our state department
and our department of defense so
our state department is doing the
diplomacy that is required
before we would win
uh um you senator shaheen on behalf of
chairman inhofe let me recognize senator
cotton
thank you senator ray i want to thank
both witnesses for appearing um
i want to make an observation upfront
when we talk about
civilian control of the military and the
implications for this waiver
uh i i don't think anyone believes that
civilian control of the military is
seriously at risk from lord austin's
nomination
we all have immense respect for what
often uh in his
uniform within its respect for general
mark miller the chairman of the joint
chiefs
uh and the other senior leaders of our
armed forces and our combatant commands
so the question we're really facing here
is whether the
experiences and the skills and the
relationships
that career military officers bring to
the job
after being recently retired is right
for that job
um so i want to speak first to our
witnesses about some perceptions
um ms cohen you write the idea that
we're going to confirm recently
retired flag officers uh to be secretary
of defense
two administrations in a row can help
create the perception
that the terminal point in one's
military career
is not being of course our officers but
rather being secretary of defense
is there any way that we can avoid that
perception given the fact that actions
speak louder than words if we move
forward with this waiver
thank you senator um as i said i do
think that granting two waivers in a row
will seriously weaken
uh the norm of this being an exception
rather than the rule
do you think that uh it will seriously
um implicate you know
this this problem that um exactly the
way you describe it that the
uh culmination of an officer's career is
not four-star
um but secretary of defense um can that
be mitigated
um that will be difficult i think the
only way that
this chamber can mitigate that is to be
very very clear
in the specific reasons that they think
mr austin is the right person for this
job at this time
and especially to maintain the statute
as it stands
not to simply think that well we've
granted two exceptions in a row and
therefore the statute is dead and
and doesn't really count as law anymore
but to emphasize
that that uh this chamber really
believes in the principle
um and is making an exception to what
they think is an important rule
thank you and uh also you point out a
couple other perceptions
expertise
in nature um but the inherently
political nature
um when the secretary of defense has to
engage
sometimes repeated political disputes
with inside the market events between
services and between
the most consequential and successful
secretaries of defense
uh all had significant political
experience
three of them had partisan experience
either kathleen berger
dick cheney uh leon panetta and bob
gates
a lot of political experience being a
university president texas a m as well
um the skills and experiences
that you gain in the military which is
inherently apolitical and designed to be
so
in our republic prepare you for all of
those political
um disputes that you might have a
secretary of defense
senator i think the short answer to that
is no um i think
obviously the experience you gain as a
forced-on military officer is
immense it's important it's helpful to
understanding all of the things that
need to be done
in the in the well to understanding many
of the things that need to be done
in the department of defense um but as
you point out
many of our most successful secretaries
of defense have not only extensive
inter-agency experience but sometimes
also legislative experience
and it is simply not the case that a
military officer who has spent
his or her entire career again four star
officers
the higher you get in the military
hierarchy the more alike those officers
are and many of them come from combat
arms backgrounds
like yourself and that
is a certain type of experience that is
important and helpful but i do not think
comprehensive
in the way that you would want a
secretary of defense um
to have experience thank you all right
thank you one final question on page 10
of your testimony you
assess the 10 years of secretary
marshall secretary mattis i commend
everyone to read those brief histories
um were those 10 years after they had
received these waivers
successes to be repeated or cautionary
tells
about the wisdom of this year cruel
health period
senator i think as dr mcinnis has really
ably demonstrated the the
job of secretary of defense is
incredibly difficult and almost no one
is ever really prepared for it
however i think that both the tenures of
secretary marshall and secretary mattis
basically reinforced the concerns of the
members of congress who made that
initial statute they relied very heavily
on their military networks
they seemed to be uncomfortable dealing
with
political issues and in marshall's case
with protecting the president
from an over-ambitious